[Musique]
bonsoir petit ami nounours est très
imprudent vous savez il se promène avec
toutes ses économies il pourrait les
perdre pas trop ce sont de belles
économies et je veux les montrer à
Nicolas et à Pimprenelle je suis sûr
qu'ils n'en ont pas autant que moi j'ai
des pièces de toutes les tailles en
argent en or ce sont de belles économies
ça mais fais attention nounours
[Musique]
qu'est-ce que c'est que ce bruit c'est
moi
[Musique]
ce joli bruit ce sont mes économies
tout se porte monnaie et plein de pièces
oui de l'argent liquide
attention ce ne sont pas des pièces pour
jouer ce sont des vrais
je ne sais pas je réfléchis
tenez c'est facile il faut viser et
lancer les pièces dans la boîte celui
qui gagne il ramasse tout quoi
toutes les pièces qui sont tombées à
côté
je sens que je vais gagner j'aurais
encore plus d'argent
[Musique]
elle est tombée sur la table mais c'est
presque dans la boîte non c'est à côté
et moi hop ensuite alors à côté
laissez-moi rire c'est facile comme tout
quand on sait viser et voilà
[Musique]
encore une autre
je te la prête mais tu me la rendras
bien sûr à moi attention
ça y est j'ai gagné gros mots
et oui
[Musique]
dans la boîte
oh je jouais presque toute mature les
mois toutes mes économies
c'est trop fort ça non
bonne nuit et bien moi parole de
nounours je j'aurais plus d'argent dans
une maison de brigand oh quel tripo je
vais me plaindre au marchand de sable tu
as raison ours et moi non plus j'aurais
plus avec cette cagnotte de pièces
bonne nuit petit frère chéri ouais bonne
nuit gros que
[Musique]
j'ai l'impression que nounours n'est pas
content oh non je ne suis pas content
j'ai perdu mes belles économies et
comment nounours en jouant oh je sais
pas trop ce n'est pas bon de jouer à
l'argent et oui nounours il ne faut
jamais jouer à l'argent ainsi on ne perd
pas tant pis pour toi c'est une bonne
leçon heureusement c'est pas preneur qui
a gagné mais je ne jouerai plus et je
vais faire d'autres économies bonne nuit
les enfants
faites de progrès
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]